yeah welcome to this video playing with
a guy from Austria wiki sneeze a not
sneaky weasel okay the car com let's
just play the the classical for a change
and immediately someone goes for an
offbeat line okay keep it simple I
believe if ifs the move that is usually
recommended here but this shouldn't be
too too bad just am trying to develop
pieces Knight f6 special d6 castles
hmm I wonder about the bishop before
yeah but not a three i will i will add
the entity to exchange the bishop not
too great came just develop him b6 is a
move that i didn't I mean this is a move
you don't like in the structure and this
is also the reason why the setup is is
even viable for white well let's say a
viable and maybe not the right word why
this is an interesting setup however
this is this wonder 192 so now he has to
had to play a three-game so just just
snap it off here come on let's just take
it to a complete development they can
player for but he has got a weak King
now this is a force I mean it was in a
way now necessary to to activate but
it's not something you you actually like
to play you would never play F for what
35 you can do that why isn't this just a
week power on on on the default okay
yeah this was just weird yeah you never
want to play a formerly to the snow is
really comfortable for black
the deep one is really a weakness and
he's got no no big idea to push it and
the the night on b3 is just terrible my
ideas if I if I can manage play fosc
forecheck 94 and then night see 52 e 40
Nazi 52 d 3 the thing is 96 so this is
why playbook t8 first so that I have 94
95 96 is not possible yeah like it's
almost winning already I think he has no
way to defend his deep on or prevent 94
93
yeah what's now 94 Knight takes d5
everything's good 93 is also good I but
ok 93 can maybe play 96 you don't want
to take night f5 gives them give them
some play Knightly force also not so
clear ok maybe maybe
okay let's let's go him this shouldn't
be bad at all 96 okay but even you
should even be able to to stand this
Nyjah form we can net energy and gamble
on that don't think too much Knight f3
and a deft with is a big threat this
will win win the Owls probably willing
two of two exchanges or something
okay so this one that take take the two
exchanged check oh wait that's Luke c6
no he never he never ever gave the check
so I can just wrap it it's much easier
okay just a queen is a queen and an
extra Queen was very nice guys got the
c6 pawn but quite resigned yeah yeah it
was really am you must be cautious Air
Force Air Force weakening a but not not
fatal but d phi f really this
immediately needs to an excellent game
for black the computer doesn't really
agree but it shows that there are some
room for improvement this is just just a
terrible position for what it wants to
play a for which I which I see this is
better than than the game this is
already get some get soggy and this is
the cs flat out winning him he needs to
play a 4 ok as i see that but why does
in big trouble with this weekend king
the week d5 pawn and so on and TM this
is naji forces the winning move i can
also take on c6 horses is minus 3 here
yeah it was just weakening too much and
also f4 it's just something you need to
really be aware of it looks like a
harmless way to to set up but i mean
right here he had the porn f3 so f was a
logical move to do but let's consider
the pawn would be on f 2 f 4 as the
movie would never have a play because it
just weakens some your whole camp and he
was somehow provoked to do that because
i played this specially for move and
provoked f3 which I don't like really
but okay here he was yeah he was obliged
almost to do that and then it gets it
gets a bit tricky with the weaknesses
alright thanks for watching